Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters and another presentation on understanding your DNA.
This one is the CBS Transulferation Pathway.
Sometimes called the CBS Pathway because CBS is the first G in this pathway,
but it's technically called the Transulferation Pathway.
And
again, if you're new to 23 and B or you don't even know what genetics are about, you start with a genetic
23 and B test.
And hopefully we're going to light you on all this is about if this if you just come across this video,
please go to Cutters, click and hit the genetics tab that will help you understand.
This is more of a deeper video here.
The Transulferation Pathway is how you get rid of more trash in your body, at least that's a piece of it.
So it is part of detoxification in the sense more so cellular,
getting rid of reactive nitrogen species and reactive oxygen species, free radicals,
really is what we're talking about getting rid of.
This pathway platter is thank you to SeekingHealth.org because they made this chart for us.
It's a beautiful picture and I like to use pictures as much as possible.
So this is the CBS pathway here.
It looks really super complicated, but the first gene in there, you can see the center top says homocysteed
and homocysteed comes out of the methionine pathway and goes into that first gene family,
that CBS family of genes in order to go through this pathway.
And the purpose of this pathway is to help feed the glutathione pathway,
which glutathione is your made cellular antioxidant.
It feeds SOD, which is another made antioxidant, which gets rid of superoxide.
It helps prevent peroxidite rate formation.
This pathway also gets rid of sulfites and sulfites.
It feeds the citric acid cycle, super, super important.
So people that have sulfite allergies,
typically they'll say, oh, I can't drink wine.
It's got to be sulfites. I think you have a sulfite allergy.
Typically, it's not sulfite allergy.
It is defects in this CBS pathway.
That's my belief, not that you can't have a sulfite allergy, but dide-de-dide percent of the time,
it's defects of this pathway.
And you help support this pathway, and their sulfite allergy goes away.
Well, it doesn't really go away.
But pathway supported, so you don't have as many issues of that anymore.
This is the CBS gene family.
This is a clip from the report that you'll see.
Probably the most important of these genes in this first section here is the CBS 699 gene.
Defects of that are going to cause issues in this pathway.
This is one that I like to support, and one of the first ones I like to support
if a person has G defects in here.
Also, this ammonia and glutamate production issues in this pathway,
so if you have defects in this pathway, you're going to have excess ammonia production,
excess glutamate production.
So symptoms of that are, I mean, literally, excess ammonia production
can be fibromyalgia in itself, right there.
Chronic aches and pains, chronic pain, chronic issues,
chronic fatigue is excess ammonia production.
Also, I didn't tie it into this, but the urea cycle,
which is much farther down in your genetic slip report,
ties exactly into this too.
So if you have a lot of defects in the urea cycle genes,
there are a lot of urea cycle genes that you don't get rid of ammonia very well at all.
You're producing it too much if you've got defects in this pathway,
and that if you have urea cycle, defects, you don't get rid of it very well.
So you've got the double whammy.
Same thing with glutamate.
We'll talk a lot more about glutamate when we get into the biopterid pathway,
but defects in the CBS pathway, you produce excess glutamate,
and if you have defects in your GAD genes,
and you have defects in your GLS genes, then you will not get rid of it very well at all.
So you're going to have excess glutamate.
Excess glutamate symptoms are horrible.
Person has a lot of anxiety, can't sleep, can't rest,
a lot of OCD, can't let things go perseverate on thoughts,
musculature with glutamate, they're twitchy, tight,
cramping sometimes, just, you can have heart palpitations,
you can have all sorts of things with glutamate.
Glutamate is very similar to histamine, high histamine symptoms as well.
We see that a lot, and that is a huge piece of people's problem,
is that glutamate, what, and I really hung down that a lot.
So, especially when we look at your GAD genes in the biopter in pathway,
in another presentation, we'll talk more about glutamate,
but that's the big issue with people.
Partly, that has to do with food industry is putting glutamates in our foods
for the purpose of causing us to be addicted to the food,
because glutamate is a stimulatory neurotransmitter,
and it's stimulatory to your tongue receptors as well.
So, when you eat food with glutamate in it, your tongue goes,
oh, that's good stuff, and it sings a pretty song,
and it says, give me more of that.
And so, the food industry purposely puts that in there.
That's called a food flavor enhancer,
of you've heard of the most common glutamate,
bipy, butter, sodium, glutamate, MSG,
but there's at least 20 different forms of glutamate,
and thank the Food and Drug Administration,
because they have said that they don't even have to listen on the label.
So, I think somebody got a big fat check for that one,
but that's just me.
So, glutamate is very damaging.
Glutamate is an early cause of Alzheimer's glutamate.
You continue to stimulate those glutamate receptors in the brain.
It causes early dementia, causes just tons and tons of problems.
It should be outlawed.
Now, glutamate isn't necessarily bad.
Again, hit this heart again.
It's all about balance.
You need even ammonia in your body.
You need glutamate in your body.
It's about balance.
Glutamate is an excitatory neurotransmitter.
It helps you wake up in the morning.
It helps you get going.
It helps you stay awake.
It helps you be attentive.
That's what it does in your brain.
Too much of it is what we've just discussed.
Here are some symptoms of hyperamodia.
You could have growth, re-heart nation, hypothermia.
You're cold all the time.
Poor circulation, aches and pains.
I mean, these are symptoms...
I mean, you could literally take those symptoms and many people will go,
well, that's me.
That's why symptoms are right there.
Are all my problems from hyperamodia in my body?
And the answer could be yes.
But there's probably more than just this.
It's always more, isn't it?
But this is a piece.
And it's a piece often that is not addressed.
So we do want to address this.
By supporting the urea cycle,
supporting ammonia reduction.
And there's some nutrients that we may use that I may recommend with this.
So that's why we may recommend it.
If you have CBS and BHMT defects,
now you'll understand why.
Again, if you need deeper help,
this is how you go deeper.
I talked about this at every slide presentation.
So in understanding the 23,
it'd be agreements that you're going to get that,
that nutritional supplementation recommendation,
which you probably already have.
So you know, you're starting to understand
why we want to support these different things
and when we want to add these.
And understand, you're getting my nutritional supplement recommendation.
And I may go light on you right away.
And down the road, you may go.
Let's use ammonia as an example.
I think I should get ammonia scavenger.
And I want to try that.
By all means, try it.
So always start slow, though.
Just start slow and go slow.
And don't make too many changes at the same time.
So you could discern for yourself what's the right change
and what the change is doing for you.
That's my suggestion.
So hopefully this is a blessing
and you'll get more on of it as we go through.
All right, bye-bye.